[Music]  it's just first past yeah give me some  feedback anything you think of shock  absorption lateral movement cupholder  may wanna think about some AC down no  don't don't help  one hundred and thirty eight hundred  thirty-eight combat missions that's how  many I've flown Tony every one of them  could have been my last but I flew cuz  the fight needed to be fought it's the  same with these accords I signed because  it was the right thing to do and yeah  this sucks this is uh it's a bad beat  but it hasn't changed my mind  okay are you Tony  stank yes this is this is Tony stank  you're in the right place thank you for  that never dropping that by the way  table for one  mr. stank please by the bathroom  you